a Truman capote-esque little gay man who
befriends all the women and hears all
their secrets as we grieve the loss of
Leslie Jordan E.T is looking back at our
favorite moments with a beloved actor
and comedian
do you have a real housewives tagline my
mind is
my mind is like a bad neighborhood honey
you don't want to go up there alone now
when I start pouring the tea you'll know
it ain't gonna be sweet
this is how I read a scrill
my life
I don't know what's going on you can't
even see the whole thing the the pants
wow our standing room only
I hope they don't ask me to see it
because they poured me into these pants
but look isn't this gorgeous well y'all
do and people are calling me going
Leslie you're viral I said no honey I'm
fine I'm home with my mother they go no
you're Revival no really I'm fine I'm
with no I had no idea what that meant
because I think that as a gay man who
who in the 1950s and early 60s when I
came out I thought I was the only
homosexual in the face of this Earth I
don't think I'd be quite so screwed up
if I had somebody I could talk to
there's a gay subculture called Bayer
I'm an honorary Cub I go all over the
country and do bear
um Big Bear
campout events which I thought would be
very salacious and they're not it's just
a bunch of big old boys being silly
who's the latest person does the
celebrity Harry Styles Harry Styles
what and he's playing in a new movie and
in which he plays gay and then I wrote
back boy you're halfway there with your
with your outrageous outfits and
everything he's so handsome I didn't
realize he's so handsome I learned as a
teenager to be funny
primarily to keep the bullies you know
when they were coming after me that
could make them laugh and you know I
realized though that it's a gift it's a
god-given gift and it's something that I
can do right now
[Music]
all right